hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
aristipus was the founder of a minor
Socratic school which we call the
serenax and he was a student for a while
of Socrates and friend of his as well
and contemporary of Plato and xenophon
and escanese and all these other people
and he set out for himself a distinctive
approach to life for which he was
criticized by quite a few but he was
very happy with it himself and I think
one of the best places to begin in
diogenes Laertes life of aristipus is
with the passage where he's being
criticized for ordering a very expensive
bird a partridge that costs 50
drockmeyer right and somebody says would
you not have given an old he says would
you not have given an oval for it a very
small bit and the person said sure yeah
and then he says well 50 drockmeyer no
more to me and then there's another uh
discussion where he says Dionysus the uh
you know ruler who we're going to talk
about shortly gave him his choice of
three prostitutes he carried off all
three saying Paris paid dearly for the
preference uh to one out of three but he
doesn't actually have sex with the
prostitutes he takes them up to his
threshold of his door and then he says
all right see you later and he sends
them on uh his way so
what is this displaying
diogeny says something very interesting
here this shows us these sort of
incidents how aristipus typically and
the the words here in Greek hutos in
what Manner right paulus uh you know
most often how he generally is going to
engage in and then he uses two important
terms here choosing helici to you know
select one thing instead of another and
then disdaining is how it's translated
but you could also say holding in
contempt or valuing very lowly so
aristipus his life you could say is one
that's governed by the pursuit of
pleasure and philosophy is going to play
a role in that and obviously you need
money in order to pursue a lot of
Pleasures particularly if you're buying
expensive meals which he does
but how do you value these things how do
you prioritize them and this is where
his approach is actually quite
distinctive so if we look at what he
says that philosophy provides him with
there's some very interesting remarks
here that tie in with this so one of the
things that philosophy provides him with
he says is being at ease is how it's
it's translated the Greek word there is
a tarantos comes from the word for
confidence feeling you know that you're
up to something that you can handle it
tarus right which is an emotion
sometimes translated in terms of bravery
and so being at ease being confident in
whatever Society you happen to to be in
whether you're hanging out with ordinary
people or at the court of Dionysus
teaching philosophy going on a c Voyage
whatever it happens to be you know how
to handle it another thing that he says
that's really quite interesting is
um about what would happen he says what
advantage what what benefits is there
for those who study philosophy or those
who are pursuing philosophy
and he says that if all laws and laws
here includes Norms Customs right if all
of them should be repealed or taken away
then we he uses the the term there uh
you know first person plural we would
continue to live the same sort of life
why because they're not dependent on
external penalties or social pressure or
anything like that in order for them to
pursue what they think is the best and
most rational life so that's uh quite
important he also has a few remarks
about philosophy as being the
culmination of education and before that
he he's asked how do the educated those
who've undergone some sort of
development how do they differ from the
uneducated he says well just like horses
that have been trained differ from
untrained horses right so the horses
that are untrained are just following
their instincts those that are trained
can actually do something different and
if they're educated in the right way
they can be their own masters right and
so
a little bit later
um here we go he's he's talking about uh
those who are studying all sorts of
things uh those who go through the
ordinary curriculum but stop short of
philosophy he used to compare to the
suitors of Penelope so if you don't know
what the reference there is
um Odysseus goes away to war and it
takes him 20 years to come back
meanwhile there are people on Ithaca who
are trying to pursue his wife so they
can marry her not just have sex with her
they're already having sex with all of
the household servants but so that they
can get the house right and so he says
the suitors won malantho paladora the
rest of the handmaidens but we're
anything but successful in the wing of
the mistress meaning that they study all
this other great stuff but they don't
study the one thing that would put it
all into perspective that would allow
them to figure out how to structure
their life and so what is aristipus's
life like well we see both in the
description of his philosophical
position and in the things that he does
he pursues Pleasures as a matter of fact
he goes for the pleasures that are close
at hand he's uh you know willing to
spend plenty of money for the pleasures
that he's got he's willing to exchange
that and says he derived pleasure from
what is present and did not toil to
procure the enjoyment of something not
present so you know rather than like
clean his own vegetables like diogenes
does he'll go to the court of uh the
tyrants and you know hang out with him
and chat with him and eat his food and
stuff like that and then he gets you
know he gets criticized for that what
about this whole thing of taking money
or taking benefits well we learn that
aristipus is a Socratic philosopher who
does in fact take money for teaching and
this comes up several times right
he was the first of the followers of
Socrates to charge fees to take money
for what he's doing
but it's interesting here and this
really sheds a light on some things he
sends some of the money to Socrates you
know we often portray stocks oh I am not
like these sophists who take money for
educating people and we hold them up as
this High very often unrealistic
standard
they're a step is if this is actually
correct was helping to support his old
teacher right and sometimes Socrates
would return the stuff saying that the
supernatural sign would not let him take
it right
um so you know this is going to come up
at several different points this money
making issue and this uh relationship to
Socrates now he will say interestingly
later on uh when uh he's being asked
about
um you know why he's he's taking money
that he here we go when I needed wisdom
I went to Socrates now that I need money
I come to you Socrates literally that
you know he he does have a pot to piss
in but not much more than that right and
he's dependent on his followers helping
him out uh but he has wisdom that
aristipus can glean or gain from him
everybody else is there as somebody who
can contribute the the funds right so
that is a an interesting observation
um you know he also talks about rich
people and philosophers and this puts
some things into perspective
um when Dionysus inquired what was the
reason that philosophers go to rich
people's houses while the rich people no
longer visit philosophers
aristipus's reply was that the one know
what they need while the other do not so
you know philosophers know that they
need some money and they'll go to the
rich people the rich people don't really
know what they need in order to make
their lives a genuinely happy one a
self-controlled one so that's uh quite a
good observation here a little bit later
somebody's saying that he always saw
philosophers at Rich men's doors and
aristipus says well sure Physicians are
in attendance on those who are sick but
no one for that reason would prefer
being sick to being a physician and in
fact aristipus thinks that the
philosophical life is a life with
greater value as is revealed by a non-uh
monetary one they're overtaken by a
storm and somebody says we plain men are
not alarmed are you philosoph first turn
cowards and he says well the lives at
stake in the two cases are not actually
comparable meaning that the
Philosopher's life is much more valuable
not you know in terms of social status
or wealth or stuff like that but in
terms of
attaining happiness
he teaches his friends according to this
they ask him why do you take money from
your friends and he says well to teach
them how to spend their money well
effectively how to
pick out the right things to spend money
on which is an interesting rejoinder and
then he's got a willingness not only to
do things to get the money that he needs
as a matter of fact here's here's a
really funny uh case with Dionysus that
I I can't resist bringing up at this
point
um Dionysus
was asked for some money and he says no
you told me the wise person would never
be in want and so then aristipus says
well pay me now and then we'll discuss
the question and so Dionysus pays him
and then he says now you see do you not
that I was not found wanting meaning
that I knew where to get the money from
namely you sucker who gave me the money
asking about the very question now I'm
I'm set and I'm answering your question
and look I am a wise man who is in fact
doing quite well there is this
willingness to cast money away which we
see in for example uh
a case where he's got so much money that
uh
um he's his his uh servant can't carry
it all and so you know he uh tells him
well you know leave it behind then we
don't actually need all of this and then
there's a case where uh he throws his
money overboard when pirates are coming
in
um yeah here's here's the the earlier
one pour away the greater part and carry
no more than you can manage just take
what you actually need the Second Story
being once on a voyage when he
discovered the vessel to be manned by
Pirates he took out his money began to
count it and then by carelessness as if
by that he let the money fall into the
sea and broke out into lamentation
another version of the story says the
further remark it was better for the
money to perish on account of aristipus
than for aristipus to perish on account
of the money right so he's he's got a
good sense of the value The Limited
value the relative value of money
there's also a recognition of the need
for money and right after this uh is
where we've got that quip about when I
needed wisdom I went to Socrates I come
to you for money
but he goes on just a little bit before
that Dionysus asked him what he was come
for and he said it was to impart what he
had and obtain what he had not meaning
I'll give you some of my wisdom my
guidance and how to live your life
and uh you will give me funds in return
there's actually a great story as well
about uh somebody who wants to hire him
to to teach his his kids here we go
um
when someone brought his son as a pupil
he asked for a fee of 500 Rock mine
that's kind of a lot of money the father
objected for that some I can buy a slave
and aristipus says well go ahead buddy
then you will have two meaning that your
your son won't learn anything and will
be a you know poor manager of his life
which
basically makes him a slave to whatever
uh he happens to pursue could be money
could be pleasure could be Prestige
could be all sorts of things but he's
not going to be living the philosophical
life unless you pay me the money to to
do this so what we see here in this
relation to money is that there's a
recognition that you know money gets
things done you do need it for some
degree but you don't want to be beholden
to it and you can boldly ask people for
it because it is of lesser value than
the things that aristipus considers to
be good and other people
recognize as good in him as a
philosopher
he gets criticized quite often by a
number of people for accommodating
himself too much to Dionysus to being
too agreeable right and one prime
example of this uh so you know there's
there's really two big criticizers here
there's diogenes the the cynic and so
he's at one extreme and he's saying oh
you know you're just a kiss Bots to
tyrants and then there's Plato now Plato
himself hangs out with Dionysus but
Plato sets down uh certain limits that
aristipus doesn't think you actually
need to do so here's a story that
illustrates this
um
one day Dionysus over the wine meaning
drunk commanded everyone to put on
purple and dance so get in your really
fancy stuff and dance around Plato
declined quoting the line I could not
stoop to put on women's robes aristepus
however put on the dress and as he was
about to dance was ready with the
repartee even among the bacchic revelry
true modesty will not be put to shame
meaning I can do this stupid thing for
you but it's just like being at a
festival
it's just for play it's not really
affecting me in my core Plato you're
going to be a stick in the mud over
there I'll I'll go along with it because
you know dearnesses is the one who is uh
running the party in this case and so
what this shows is a certain attitude of
recognition but also freedom in relation
to the wealthy and the powerful he also
as we put it out earlier gets criticism
sized quite a bit for extravagance in
spending and his response is that's what
money is for
to attain the things that you actually
want if you're willing to spend this
much on this
well then why not more I mean look at
what people do during festivals for the
gods look at what Dionysus himself does
and you say that he's not a bad guy so
if if it's okay for them to be
extravagant in those situations or in
this person's uh power seat or something
like that well why isn't it okay for me
to spend money however I see fit you
probably would do the same if you
actually had that much money That's how
little money has a hold over me similar
to how he's going to talk about pleasure
one of the you know key ideas for the
Sierra next school pleasure is the good
but
he will actually say that it's not
abstinence from Pleasures that is best
but Mastery over them
without ever being worsted without ever
being controlled by them right
so you know
he has the same attitude towards wealth
towards social Prestige all of it
feeds back into this you know choosing
and having contempt not caring about the
right things and being at ease being a
person who can run their own life
without a lot of outside guidance or
interference because they've literally
become like a law on to themselves and
that is the culmination of Education
philosophy put into practical life in
one's choices and the things that one
just doesn't care about